vi siete mai chiesti Qual è il più
grande desiderio e allo stesso tempo
limite della razza umana ci avete mai
pensato
Io personalmente credo che sia quello di
volare
Non tanto per carità per sogno
aspirazione Eh non ci pensate Ma perché
a noi che un robot così sia in grado di
volare Noi no ci crea un complesso di
inferiorità che neanche Napoleone
eppure in realtà noi ci abbiamo sempre
provato il problema qual è stato che
siamo sempre stati bloccati dalla
gravità finché nel 1903 due fratelli
dell'Ohio sbagliando a leggere le
istruzioni della libreria Billy di Ikea
si ritrovano con questo robot qui
le seguire sempre le istruzioni il primo
aereo della storia ok si alzava più o
meno così un metro e mezzo non di più
però era un inizio e sapete qual è la
cosa più sconvolgente che di lì a poco
più di 40 anni saremmo arrivati a vedere
questo Yuri Gagarin il primo essere
umano nello spazio
è assurdo se ci pensate avevamo appena
conquistato l'aria però non ci bastava
volevamo di più volevamo qualcosa che ci
desse una nuova sensazione quella di
abbattere un limite e se ci pensate
questa storia ricorre sempre nell'arco
della storia umana ci poniamo dei limiti
E poi vogliamo Porcell degli altri
perché quella sensazione di romperli ci
serve
adesso oggi voglio darvi una possibilità
quella di provare voi stessi la
sensazione che vuol dire rompere un
limite
Cercate di stare un attimo tranquilli
siete seduti rilassatevi fa caldo
Respirate Se volete Provate a chiudere
gli occhi
pensate di essere nel vostro posto
sicuro ok Non c'è nessuno preoccupazione
Respirate ancora
e poi a un certo punto sentite nelle
cuffie la voce del capcom
quello che avete appena sentito è il
suono di un limite che viene infranto
Anzi per lo specifico più di uno e lo
avete fatto se io minimamente ho avuto
successo nello stesso modo in cui lo
provano gli astronauti quindi non con
ansia o paura salire una roba del genere
metterebbe paura a tutti ma non agli
Astronauti l'avete provato con serenità
perché non andiamo nello spazio tenendo
le dita incrociate
perché lo space shuttle Questo era il
suono che faceva lo space shuttle quando
partiva da Cape Canaveral in Florida per
andare nello spazio e perché lo space
shuttle perché secondo me è l'emblema di
quello che vuol dire superare un limite
primo fra tutti un limite Ricordatevi
che richiede un costo per essere
superato Quanto alto questo costo Beh la
NASA fa i conti una possibilità di un
incidente fatale nei primi cinque lanci
dello Space Shuttle era di uno a nove ne
hanno lanciati cinque altri quattro
forse Sarebbero esplosi tutti e quattro
nel 1990 dopo più di 30 lanci era di 1 a
38 ora non so quanti di voi anzi di noi
oggi accetterebbero un rischio simile
nella vita
Però appunto lo space shuttle ci dà
questa opportunità ci dà l'idea di
quello che è la natura umana perché
nonostante queste possibilità che per
carità la vita contempla sempre la
possibilità della morte però qui sono
molto alte allo stesso tempo flotteri
Astronauti Si sono seduti su di lui per
andare in orbita hanno deciso di correre
quel rischio e hanno sentito lo stesso
identico suono che avete sentito voi
oggi
vedete nel 1984 la NASA decise di
portare sullo shuttle una nuova
invenzione che era Questa tuta qua che
si chiama mmu è fondamentalmente una
tuta che si mette sopra la tuta normale
degli Astronauti e che ha di la
possibilità di espellere dei piccoli
oggetti d'aria che permettono
l'astronauta di muoversi liberamente
nello spazio se avete visto il film
Gravity è quella con cui il George
Clooney si muove senza senso in giro
all'inizio bene Questa tuta però ebbe un
problema la NASA la ritirò dopo appena 3
missioni
perché secondo la NASA perché era
ritenuta troppo pericolosa
non è la versione ufficiale Questa tuta
aveva un altro problema un problema
enorme l'indole umana perché sapete
quale fu la prima cosa che gli
astronauti pensarono quando seppero che
era disponibile per la loro missione
Vediamo chi riesce andare più lontano
ora vi faccio vedere questa foto nella
sua prospettiva reale
questo è Bruce macandless secondo ha più
di 90 metri dallo Space Shuttle e
l'attuale record ha più di 90 metri
dall'unica cosa che può garantirgli di
tornare a casa sano e salvo perché se
dovesse succedere qualcosa lui
rimarrebbe lì lo shuttle non era in
grado di andarlo a prendere
Cominciate a capire di cosa stiamo
parlando cioè ogni volta che rompiamo un
limite niente Noi dobbiamo porcerne un
altro perché ne abbiamo bisogno
però abbiamo detto che comunque correre
questi rischi
alla fine ha un costo e non si può
vincere sempre
però Tuttavia tutti gli astronauti che
sono Si sono seduti sullo Shuttle che
sono andato nello spazio hanno deciso di
correre quel rischio però di fronte a
una cosa del genere la domanda che ci
facciamo è ne valeva la pena
Secondo me sì Secondo me per qualcosa di
più importante di più grande Sì ma
qualcosa di più grande cosa perché cosa
ci può essere di più importante di
andare nello spazio e correre quel
rischio Cosa può valere tanto
gli altri esseri umani per aiutare gli
altri a superare i loro limiti sono
limiti che sono difficilissimi da
superare spesso noi ce ne dimentichiamo
o forse non vogliamo neanche vederli
forse non ci riguardano Ma perché
dovrebbero essere da meno
non avrebbe senso però corre quel
rischio può significare tanto correre un
rischio così grande come quello di
andare nello spazio può significare dare
una chance a qualcun altro per superare
il proprio limite
come
Beh la NASA nel 2005 decide di iniziare
un nuovo programma congiunto tra lo
space shuttle della Stazione Spaziale
internazionale per coltivare piante
nello spazio è una roba difficilissima
da fare per la scarsità di luce naturale
che c'è per cui hanno deciso di
inventare queste lampade a led di questo
colore violaceo che permettono
fondamentalmente di coltivare le piante
negli ambienti più ostili del mondo
bene La ricerca è un successo clamoroso
le piante crescono forti rigogliose
coltiviamo lattuga qualunque cosa sulla
stazione spaziale internazionale ma non
è un successo per questo
vedete per i pazienti oncologici che
hanno sofferto di un cancro oppure di
leucemia Specialmente per chi ha subito
un trapianto uno degli effetti
collaterali peggiori è quello della
secchezza delle mucose ovvero tutte le
cose della parte superiore del corpo
tendono a seccarsi e Provocano dei
dolori lancinanti nel 2008 abbiamo
scoperto che l'applicazione a luce
pulsante della stessa identica luce che
fa crescere le piante nello spazio
permette di ridurre questo dolore
dell'80%, e permette il passaggio a dose
di farmaci più basse nella metà del
tempo
o ancora leva le famose camminate
spaziali quelle che servono per riparare
la stazione spaziale internazionale
durante queste camminate gli astronauti
che si trovano all'esterno della
Stazione hanno pochissimi mezzi di
comunicazione principalmente una
telecamera montata sul casco un
microfono con un auricolare e una lista
di cose da fare bene Per ovviare a
questo problema l'agenzia spaziale
Europea ha creato un sistema molto
particolare che permette di proiettare
sugli occhi degli Astronauti una serie
di informazioni aggiuntive in tempo
reale sulla loro missione questo stesso
identico sistema oggi è utilizzato per
ridare voce alle persone con malattie
degenerative che hanno perso l'uso della
parola proiettando sui loro occhi delle
tastiere con cui possono comunicare di
nuovo
il paziente più famoso che ha utilizzato
questa tecnologia per anni che forse
conoscerete era affetto da sla ed era
Stephen Hawking
infine durante una semplice ricerca
sulle alte velocità un ingegnere della
NASA creò una colla molto particolare
che serviva per ricoprire i razzi con
cui andavano nello spazio questa questo
polimero era fantastico Perché
addirittura non riusciva a essere
attaccato da nessun tipo di liquido era
estremamente resistente e soprattutto
Era ehm aveva la possibilità di
di non condurre elettricità
bene questo stesso polimero oggi si
trova in ogni singolo pacemaker che
viene impiantato nell'intero pianeta si
dice che dal 2016 a oggi il pacemaker
abbia salvato più di un milione e mezzo
di vite
e anzi un milione e mezzo più una quella
di mio nonno che oggi ha qua in questa
sala Grazie a questo dispositivo e a
questa invenzione
Grazie
Questo è quello di cui vi parlavo Questo
è quello che affrontiamo perché
affrontiamo tutte queste cose
è mettere di fronte a noi un rischio
perché altri possano effettivamente
avere una chance di superare i loro di
limiti il coraggio di uno può
significare tanto per veramente molti
Ok stop al timer
questo mio discorso sono speech è durato
all'incirca 12 minuti Questo è lo stesso
identico tempo che lo space shuttle
impiegava da che Canaveral quando veniva
lanciato per andare in orbita e lo
stesso tempo che ad un astronauta
serviva per cambiare la vita di milioni
di persone
Ora sta a voi sta a voi Oggi quando
uscite tra quella porta capire come i
vostri 12 minuti possono cambiare cosa
c'è là fuori perché non siete da meno ve
lo posso assicurare in 12 minuti anche
voi potete cambiare la vita di qualcuno
grazie
[Applauso]